uh there's work to be done from mother
nature check this out beautiful live
picture from our camera on top of the
uh red rock resort there's resorts world
on the north end of the strip but plenty
of other
great hotels and there's of course the
link and the rio
and the pre-dawns early let's check out
the official number for you at mccarran
it was 77 an hour ago we dropped a
degree
humidity is up there at 43 the dew point
52 so yes it feels a little bit muggy
there's still some juice in the
atmosphere
i expect this is going to dry out as we
get through the day in fact it's going
to warm up so much national weather
service already issuing an excessive
heat watch
for sunday las vegas not included but
northwest clark county southwest clark
county southern nye and much of san
bernardino county
so the rain it moved on very quickly but
man when it came down it sure did come
down let's get you over the next couple
of hours back to the mid 80s by 8 with a
lot of sunshine
a couple of clouds around between noon
and 3 95
at noon going for 101 you knew triple
digits weren't going to come back
and 99 still at 6 pm